leafy and green and right in the heart
of the city the residents of the
apartment building vented Cinque bare
they have it all the facade is covered
with a hundred and fifty trees they
clean the air produce oxygen and absorb
noise from the street there are 63
apartments in this green living project
revenue hi I'm Anita and I'd like to
show you what it's like living here
amici Jo Valley has lived here for five
years now she moved in right after it
was completed
[Music]
I don't know Sesame's on the left-hand
side there's a small pool total ACOs
through Sue Ellen
the whole building consists of wood
trees and steel as you can see here
these aren't real tree trunks but the
rusting steel it's in the best part of
the house is the garden well you're
going down actually it's more like a
mini forest stuff for a stuff in the
summer the trees provide shade that
cools down the building so there's no
need for air conditioning and in winter
when their branches are bare they let in
more warm sunlight reducing the heating
bills booting up all of the flats have
different floor plans and that sounds up
there I'm going to show you around now
the building is mainly made of steel and
untreated large wood both materials can
adapt to their environment and are tough
and durable
[Music]
is that come in let's look around our
apartment when Anita needs to heat her
place she uses environmentally friendly
geothermal energy what you immediately
notice about this room of the huge
windows which leads straight onto the
terrace Padano directamente sourced a
lot so the apartment has an additional
72 square metres of space outside we
like eating outside in the summer all of
the terraces have these huge planters
Vakula pianta it's wonderful because you
can see how the trees change through the
seasons and of course in autumn it's
particularly attractive
[Music]
mayordomo say watch the construction
step by step because we used to live
behind it
somebody must be Moreland we were always
very fascinated by what was being
created here toka we always wanted an
apartment with big windows and lots of
greenery and in the end we found it
right outside our door
vente Cinque Verde is the perfect
solution for city dwellers who missed
the countryside but rarely get out into
it it brings nature to them